hello and welcome to the 2020 virtual
cornell hemp research team field day
my name is jennifer starr and i am the
research support specialist for dr gary
bergstrom's field crops pathology
laboratory
i also work alongside kevin myers who
helps with scouting for hemp disease and
does our molecular testing
today i'll be giving a brief overview of
foliar diseases and possible
management strategies i want to focus
this talk on just a few things
to highlight i will start with septoria
leaf spot
and bipolaris leaf spot also known as
hemp leaf spot
then i will move to lesser impact
emerging leaf diseases
such as downing mildew and hemp rust
septorial leaf spot is caused by the
fungus septoria species
and symptoms begin on the lower leaves
of the plant
as irregularly shaped spots with yellow
margins
these spots expand over time turn brown
and the yellow margins broaden to look
something like this
this was observed in eastern new york in
2019
and in eastern and western new york in
2020
in this slide i have a video of what
septorial leaf spot looks like in the
field
and as you can see it is on the lower
leaves and we see those brown
spots with the bigger yellow margins
this is septorial leaf spot
the next highlight is bipolaris leaf
spot also known as hemp leaf spot
this is caused by a fungus that's being
classified as bipolaris gigantia
related to dreschlera gigantea
symptoms start as round specks and spots
that coalesce over time
and sometimes they have a dark margin
here with lighter tan interiors or
sometimes don't have any margin at all
we have noticed this leaf spot disease
since
cornell's hemp team started the program
a few years back and we usually notice
this
at the end of the growing season and
we've noticed throughout new york state
this is not a super high impact
disease as other states have seen it
defoliate plants we have not seen that
yet
in new york state
next up we have downy mildew
lesser impact emerging disease
this is caused by pseudopornosphera
canabina
which has just been recently id'd by
sequencing
last week the spots start out as these
light green
yellow spots with necrotic margins and
the lower surface of the leaf you can
actually see the fungus growing
in humid conditions or if you catch it
in the morning time when the dew is
still on the plant
later on the lesions become a little
more angular
and are defined by the leaf veins
of the hemp plant this was just recently
observed in ithaca
last week so in 2020
and in the next slide i have a video of
what it looks like on
the plant
and this is a good example of how
the veins of the leaf are demarcating
the spot
and confining it as you see here
this is downy mildew on hemp
our last feature is hemp rust
and hemp rust has been morphologically
identified as urido cregariana
and again this is something we're going
to want to be looking on the lower
surface of the leaf
we have yellow to orange pustules or
spots on the lower surface
and on the upper surface we have these
necrotic areas with very faint chlorosis
around them and then sometimes rust
disease systems have alternate hosts to
complete their life cycle
we have not found an alternate host with
this hemp rust
sometimes breast disease systems don't
have alternate hosts
we found this last year at the end of
the growing season in october of 2019
we will be looking again this year
for this so we can try to study it
further
the following slide is a close-up of
what the pustule looks like
on the under surface of the leaf and
what is inside that pustule
these are uradiniospores of hemp rust
we do see other hemp leaf spots
i wanted to include a quick
summary of those here
we see cristulariella zonate leaf spot
we see a circosporal
leaf spot we see some philium leaf spot
and we also see a number of other
diseases that are not leaf spots
we see fusarium bud light which could
have
implications for a quality of flowers
and grain
we see fusarium wilt we see white molds
and we see botrytis gray mold so as you
can see in addition to leaf spot
diseases we do
see and work on other diseases that are
affecting hemp
so possible product treatments we are
directing
growers to go to the dec
new york dec web page at this address
and go to pesticide product information
hit search
this will bring you to advanced search
you want to click
that press search which will then bring
you
to pesticide use you want to choose hemp
industrial hit search that will bring up
about 98 products most of which
are biologic in nature some bacillus
type products
you want to check the labels on those to
make sure hemp is included
all of this information again is present
on the cornell hemp
webpage under the faq heading
in addition to the dec web page we want
to use best agronomic practices
this will be second nature to seasoned
growers and producers
but we want to start with prevention
with having reliable seed source
and good soil health it is a myth that
hemp can be produced on marginal soils
we want fertile soil well-drained soil
we want our plant spacing to be such
where we're
reducing the humidity between the plants
because
fungus really loves to be in humid
places
it encourages its growth sanitation very
important
we want to remove debris off-site you
may burn it you might compost it but we
want it away from the hemp field
weed control also very important we have
noticed cercospora growing on weeds we
have noticed
downy mildew growing on weeds are those
weeds vectors
for fungal growth to the hemp or is it
the other way around we are still
investigating that
but it's important to keep those weeds
in control and out of the way
crop rotation also something to note
edible beans soybeans sunflowers
and their white molds probably not a
great idea to
follow hemp after those crops also in
question
recently corn and cereal crops producing
mycotoxins will be wise to put
hemp after those crops and then
resistant cultivars
something that our program here at
cornell are working towards
now
if you have questions about your hemp
crop
and have problems and want some
diagnostics
it may be wise for you to contact your
cornell
cooperative extension educator if you
don't know who yours
is you may go to the cornell hemp page
and find who your representative is
if you would like to submit samples to
my lab you may submit them through your
cornell cooperative extension
educator through them to us
we may not give you the best turnaround
time but it will be of no charge to you
or if you're looking for some quick
results you can use
our plant disease diagnostic clinic at
cornell
and it is a fee for service it's
relatively low
cost i believe it's 30 to 35
if you're in state 50 if you're out of
state and i've left
the contact information for you here
again all of this information
is on the cornell team webpage
i'm going to leave you with our lab's
contact information
this is dr gary bergstrom's email
address
this is my email address and our
laboratory phone number
if you have further questions after this
talk today
thanks for your time and i hope you
enjoy the rest of cornell's
virtual hemp talks today